elle s'appelle ioulia acura qui n'a elle
a 30 ans et une tonne d'ambition
tous les jours deux bouts à 5 heures du
matin direction gare de kiev ioulia est
assistante conductrice de très banal pas
ici elle est une des seules de toute la
russie
c'était mon rêve dit m et on m'a prévenu
que ce serait tout un exploit
son poste est un des 456 interdit aux
femmes depuis les années 70
des travaux jugés trop pénible trop
dangereux ou simplement nocifs pour la
santé des femmes
en vertu de l'article 253 du code du
travail
c'est pourquoi à moscou vous verrez par
exemple des femmes conduire les tramways
mais paul métro jamais pas question
manque de lumière vibrations travailler
sous terre ou sur les rails
à l'exception des tâches ménagères dit
la loi nuit au système reproductif des
fans importe qu'on m'a raconté des
histoires terribles pour me dissuader de
conduire le trait si elle s'est rendue
jusque ici c'est parce qu'elle est têtu
et l'a convaincu la compagnie aero
express de demander une exemption
officiel
osez de plus en plus de femmes défient
la loi comme ces fiers camionneuse un
autre métier aux dépens du tout comme la
majorité des travaux qui requiert de
soulever des poids lourds
les fonds se débrouille la femme russe
c'est toujours quelqu'un qui est plus
fort que l'homme
c'est pourquoi cette idée féministe
d'aller chez les autorités et 2
faire un lobbying de quelques mois c'est
pour cela que cette histoire n'est pas
du tout russe
on se demande où on se débrouille sans
loi et sans autorité
m
un héritage des soviets qui ont proclamé
l'égalité absolue des hommes et des
femmes la professeure
les russes ont été les premières à
obtenir le droit de vote
même le droit de se faire avorter
[Musique]
mais ce même régime qui a envoyé la
première femme dans l'espace décide
herminis 74 de les écarter de centaines
de postes pour protéger leurs capacités
reproductives en l'an 2000 le président
poutine
on a fait la loi officielle du pit avait
attaqué mais parce qu'on définit la
femme en russie par son rôle de mère
ouais très important chez nous c'est
très important et c'est un frère caïques
dans notre société on nous dit que c'est
pas de la discrimination mais une
protection explique halina une des rares
femmes qui travaillent sur un chantier
de construction
il a fallu venir jusqu'à
saint-pétersbourg pour la trouver son
rapport elle nous raconte son chemin de
croix pendant des années personne ne
voulait l'embauché ce qu'elle est une
femme ses patrons ont eux aussi de bonne
foi payer pour un certificat d'exemption
pour qu'elle puisse conduire une
excavatrice
c'est très frustrant ça m'enrage encore
aujourd'hui d'y penser diana c'est
exactement ce que l'avocat dimitri
bertaina va plaider jusqu'en cour
suprême de russie au nom d'une autre
femme qui elle voulait être capitaine de
navire à samara la fa lui qui dépose une
plainte à l'onu pour que la cour ici
leur donne enfin raison des années plus
tard une victoire symbolique dit il qui
aura au moins forcé une discussion en
russie
cet automne le président poutine a même
profité du forum des femmes de saint
pétersbourg pour annoncer que la liste
des postes interdit serait révisée ce
terrible et il est hors de question de
[Applaudissements]
signer car nous nous devons de préserver
les valeurs traditionnelles de la
famille et de la maternité a déclaré
qu'outre les applaudissements les
couloirs de l'université où enseigne
maria bien des jeunes femmes sont
d'accord avec leur président et elle dit
que pour elle une injustice serait
d'être payé moins cher qu'un homme pour
exactement la même tâche une reste
dit-elle c'est une protection
j'espère que cette mentalité changera un
jour d'y à l'ina mais ni elle ni oulia
se considèrent des modèles ou des
pionnières elles n'en sont pas moins
dans un pays où le sort des femmes se
décide au cas par cas leur persévérance
pour a fait toute la différence